- Unholiest of spirits, we offer thee
a life for a life.
Oh, mighty dark Lord,
by whom all is set to fire,
(chanting in foreign language)
thy power be thy path,
thy will my desire.
(suspenseful music)
- Sabrina,
are you sure about this?
- I have to be.
(whimpers)
(thud)
- The hounds invoked.
- [All] The door opened.
The price paid in blood.
Thomas Kinkle,
we entreat thee.
Rise!
(suspenseful music)
- [Sabrina] Tommy?
(door bangs shut)
- He won't answer you.
- How's he doing?
(sighs)
- I'll show you.
Watch.
- Oh my god!
- At first,
I thought he was getting better,
that he was remembering.
That's all he'll do.
React.
Like a robot.
(puking)
(coughing)
(gasping)
- Welcome back, sister.
(gasps)
- Where am I?
Where was I?
- So you didn't kill her?
- We did.
But only because Sabrina had
a plan to bring Agatha back.
- [All] Thy power be the path,
thy will be my desire,
in hell as it is on earth.
Praise Satan.
Amen.
(Agatha gagging)
- Agatha?
Agatha, what's the matter?
(coughs)
(vomits)
- See this thing ain't Tommy.
I don't know what the hell
it is, but it ain't my son.
(suspenseful music)
And if you are,
you might as well have
stayed in the mines.
- Help me.
(thud)
- [Man] How did Agatha
end up a living cadaver?
Tell me everything.
- The witch they killed
and brought back to life
is getting sicker, and sicker.
That's the Grim Reaper doing it to her.
He's expecting her body.
Her suffering won't end until
there's one in the ground.
Until balance is restored.
There's so fixing it, Sabrina.
You've opened Pandora's Box.
(suspenseful music)
(knobs clicking)
(whirring)
(trickling)
(electricity buzzing)
(stomping)
(roaring)
(rattling)
(suspenseful music)
(groaning)
(screams)
- Sabrina?
What's the matter?
- When I solved the puzzle,
the Acheron configuration,
it set a demon free and now it's loose!
- Edward Spellman imprisoned me
in the Acheron puzzle for 70 years.
I'll not be caged again!
- What do you want, Hellspawn?
- First,
revenge on the family of Edward Spellman.
- Did you have to ask, love?
- And then freedom!
So I may fill the world
with my sublime nightmares.
(creepy music)
(snoring)
- Ambrose.
Ambrose!
- I'm awake, sorry!
- Nothing happened.
The mandrake spell didn't work.
So what do we do now?
- Sabrina.
(gasps)
(suspenseful music)
You're not Sabrina.
- What an awful thing to say.
(crackling)
(high pitched wail)
I know how to make you love me
and only me.
(squelching)
(high pitched wail)
Why won't you let me fix you?
- 'Cause I'm not broken!
- Theo.
You're being awfully mean.
(squelching)
(high pitched wail)
- It's not Sabrina, it's something else!
I saw it in one of my visions.
Like a twin!
- Guys.
(high pitched wail)
- You murdered my friends?
- [Rosalind] Run!
Run! Go!
- Remember, the Yule
Log is not a decoration.
It is a protection.
It must burn continuously from now,
through the shortest day,
through the longest night, until dawn.
Otherwise, Satan knows
what malevolent forces
might come down our chimney.
Creatures with, perhaps,
deadly intentions.
So let's keep the log lit, shall we?
- Warden of the longest night,
Fae things fear the yule fire's light.
But you'll find dead,
when portals laid bare.
The darkness comes to trick
and to tear.
(sizzles)
(tense music)
(chants in foreign language)
(thud)
(children laughing)
- Who's there?
♪ Have a holly jolly Christmas ♪
(metal clinking)
- Oh, that can't be good.
(children laughing)
(footsteps thudding)
(gasps)
(sewing machine puttering)
- Leticia.
Leticia!
(child laughing)
- So, it's not poltergeists.
It's the Yule Lads.
- Impish spirits of
children that come down
from the mountains every
midwinter to cause mischief
in the unguarded homes of witches.
They must have gotten in
when the yule fire went out.
- Right, so we banish the buggers?
- Well, that's not so easy, love.
The Yule Lads are like bed bugs.
Once they get into your house,
they're very difficult to get rid of.
- 'Brina,
isn't there some
witchy way we could take care of Billy?
- The next time you guys are practicing,
tie a new knot on this cord.
Billy will keep tripping over his feet.
That'll bruise his ego.
(chuckles)
- Thanks, 'Brina, you're the best.
(laughing)
Where is he?
Where's Billy?!
- Billy!
- Whoa!
(thudding)
(crack)
(Billy screaming)
(suspenseful music)
- Billy, you okay, man?
Just stay cool.
Give him some room.
Breath.
Someone go get the nurse or something.
(shouting)
(suspenseful music)
- Gendered spells of metamorphosis!
Okay, I mixed all the ingredients together
like the spell said.
Now what?
- Now it's time, Theo.
Are you ready to become?
- How will I know if the spell worked?
What if the Spellmans find out that I...
- Sleep, Theo.
And dream of the boy you'll become.
- Ow.
(dramatic music)
(knocking)
- Ms. Spellman, are you home?
I might've done something really dumb.
- Oh, sweet Satan!
- I broke in and then I
stole one of your spells
and I tried to make a
potion to help me transition
and now I'm, uh-
- Petrifying into wood.
Oh, my poor little Pinocchio in reverse.
- Ow, ow!
- I mean, that can happen
with plant-based spells.
Botanicals are tricky.
- Is there any way to stop it?
- Oh yes, yes, yes, yes.
Well, yes and no.
It's mostly no.
- You sure about this?
- Okay, all right.
So, have a nice little bite
down on that.
Good boy.
And I'm gonna hold your hand, there we go.
And we will have that arm off in no time.
Chop, chop, as they say!
(laughs nervously)
- Hold still for me, boy.
(tense music)
Hold it.
Nice and still for me now.
(thudding)
(breathing heavily)